nationally ice and the u.s customs and
border protection
have become involved in policing
protests in certain cities
while there are no reports of this in
nevada the unlv immigration clinic wants
to remind everyone that any arrest
is risky for non-citizens well
especially if you're an undocumented
immigrant
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
spoke to a human rights immigration
attorney
and shares her message to the community
we've been working on a ton of updates
almost daily
as far as just immigration concerns
martha menendez from the unlv
immigration clinic says
they are alerting non-citizens about the
risk of protesting
and what happens if they get in trouble
with the law
and are arrested we take no position as
far as
who should or should not be there
everybody has a right
to to show up but
we do want people to understand the risk
and while there has been
no reports of any arrests menendez says
her goal is to keep informing
the community while she says everyone
has a right to protest
the issues come up when someone is
arrested a lot of these things for
example daca is very
dependent on and the person not having
any
any criminal history so every time they
renew that is
reviewed again another issue whether
charges are serious or end up being
dropped
ice is called the police department does
have a history of
turning people over to ice and once in
ice custody
it can be tough to get out i want
everybody to stay
safe as much as they can obviously and
please
you know give give us a call we're here
to help if um
if anybody if you or anybody in your
family
gets arrested and they have an
immigration situation
that needs to be considered sally
caramillo 8 news now